the last time i was talking to you you
were in california with me so now you
moved you moved to freedom in florida
yeah look that was only a few months ago
right that i saw you at my place in la
and i did not you know i had a gorgeous
place i did not want to leave i had i
had two companies in la i had my
employees my life was there but at some
point the rubber meets the road and the
simple truth is the democrats their
policies either well-intentioned or not
i'm past the point of intentions at this
point uh they are destroying these
cities crime house prices homeless all
the stuff that everybody knows and the
truth is that america has an incredible
system where you can pick up and go
and one month ago
i moved here and i got to tell you the
amount of smiling people seeing real
people i haven't seen teeth in a long
time
just seeing teeth i'm not i'm literally
like in school right
but they don't it's not just that they
don't care they're throwing it in our
faces we happen to be in miami beach
right now it was literally only about
two blocks away from here that aoc was
having her margarita at noon
and while she's locking her people down
in new york while at the same time i
have no doubt has said awful things
about desantis and everyone else running
florida and it's like if you believed
any of your nonsense you would not be
coming down here to party and i know
some other parties
but not for me but that's what they're
trying to show you because they are the
elites you know they have they've
they've done something really perverse
where they've tricked mainstream media
or they've used mainstream media to
trick the masses that you guys that
conservatives that republicans are
really the elite and want to rule over
you and all of these things and it's all
a lie
when they talk about the big lie it's
like this is the their big lie is a big
lie because it's extended across
everything so you know as i just
mentioned in my talk up there it's like
as i've sort of entered this world and i
talked to guys like you and dennis
prager and glenn beck and all these guys
that i used to think were somehow the
bad guys that's like we have some
political disagreements it just doesn't
matter what we believe is that america
is fundamentally good that we want to
create the conditions so that different
people can live in different ways and
that's it and that's such a better it's
such a better
message man you know it really is but
the thing is you got 50 laboratories out
there that can show how to do things and
california is going down the wrong path
and florida's showing but the individual
can make the decision i don't envy your
position i mean look you're in
california you're doing great stuff over
there i get it like and and by the way
you know we talk about states it doesn't
mean that every single city and every
single state is exactly the same so i
would leave in la which was appropriate
it's a little different bakersfield is
definitely a little different i saw a
great concert i saw frankie valley in
bakersfield a couple years ago in a
field out there was awesome um but so it
doesn't mean that every single city and
district is exactly the same but at some
point in a place to me like california
where the governor is so out of control
who's still by the way as you obviously
know still has emergency powers like
palpatine from star wars while he goes
to cabo a couple weeks ago for vacation
with his family for a week it cost them
over 200 grand
he's going to french laundry and the
rest of it i just thought okay i'll
leave that to mccarthy i got to get out
of here he wants to raise our taxes
higher and he wants health care and for
people you know i got a guest room you
got two dogs you bring the wife i got
two dogs i got two dogs we're there
ready we're coming we're here we go oh
we see where you live now we're coming
down there but i do want to think one
thing and i don't want to keep you along
yeah
you have one who uh have one of the
first voices about what big tech has
done to silence us on our voices and
your your book uh burned this book and
you got a new one coming out and don't
burn this book
burn this book
but
you helped get rumble going yeah so
we're really for conservatives
we're making progress building we're
building things that our voice can stay
there and it might it might be a voice
that disagrees with us but they have a
right to say it there we have a right to
have that discussion you're not going to
believe this i am completely fine with
people coming on rumble to say mean
things about dave rubin and to say bad
things about the ideas i believe in and
all that no you know we did it right
here in america we did it right for 200
something years where we had this open
exchange and if somebody wanted to be in
town square screaming you could go
listen to them or believe it or not you
could walk away crazy you could actually
walk away from the screaming person
we've now decided that the screaming
person has to be listened to by
everybody at all times and you must
destroy the screaming person and you
must destroy all of your destroy all of
your values at the exact same time so
what we're building with rumble it's
just it's not rocket science i mean the
freedom of speech freedom of speech come
on say what you want to say by the way
if you do illegal stuff if you try to
sell drugs or you make a terrorist right
you got a bigger problem than us at
rumble you know what i mean like you
know some guys that are gonna the feds
are gonna come after you so i think if
we if we treat things the way most of us
actually live our lives we can build
much better products and by the way
that's very consistent with with the way
that conservatives
or just it's not even conservatives
anyone that believes in america you
believe in america then then live those
values build better products don't just
you know look the lefties and your
counterparts in congress they're just
trying to destroy the whole damn thing
and as i said they're doing a pretty
good job of it but why not just build
something better and not build back
better how about build better products
instead of playing the game that we
cannot win with those guys that's my
plan and that's why i'm thrilled you're
on rumble and now i know senator rand
paul's on there and jim jordan's
obviously on there and we're just going
to build we're going to build and build
and then we'll see what happens we want
more people to come freedom of speech
and more importantly in less than 300
days
we want the freedom for this nation so
uh we're going to make all the changes
thank you my friend great seeing you
great to see you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell